oh whoa it's all bloody Oh defeat you do
it you really want to choke around
trouble you're from that weight family
aren't you
we're not weird we don't like wrestling
how do you know if you've ever been I've
never had rectal bleeding before but I'm
pretty sure I'm not fan about how about
I shove her head up your ass then we can
find out fake anyways so you find out
Dwayne the rock Johnson wants to make a
movie about your life story tell me
about that moment when you find this out
like did you freak out what was going on
where were you
I lost my mind so it was WrestleMania
2014 in New Jersey and I hadn't debuted
on the main roster yet so I get a text
on my phone and I already met Dwayne
before but was very short like
communication thing that we had but he
texts me and it was like hey it's DJ I
like I would love to speak to you at
some point
I don't like DJ like hell it's DJ like I
don't get enough cynics Dean Malenko
who's my mentor and he was just like
Dwayne Johnson you idiot you know it was
like what so like in the movie if you've
said it already so there's the part
where Vince Vaughn hutch takes into the
room so someone from his crew came and
got me and took me to the room and he
came in and he was just like hey it's
way and I'm like you know yeah of course
yeah who were you you know I was like it
was like so I was in England film The
Fast & Furious and I just thought it was
I couldn't sleep and I was watching a
documentary fighting with my family he
was like a knight of always wonderful
just remind me of my family he was like
it was so hot felt was so beautiful we
want to make a movie on it and I was
like okay what and then he was like all
of them by the way you're gonna be debut
and Tamar are you gonna win the Divas
Championship I'm like oh well I crazy
like two minute conversation we just had
I was just like what I just start crying
and then he was like oh and another
thing like no one can know about this
and I was like good it so I had to try
and walk out the room sobbing and tamina
that never female wrestler was there and
she was she was like are you okay like I
was like yeah I'm just a big fan of duei
like I don't know it like cuz I can say
anything so I just walking around with
snot bubbles and eyelashes
everyone that's how it came about
meanwhile I was like the big one my
biggest moment to you exactly and I had
to be quiet about it I was just like how
do I do
I mean a cold my parents and my family
but so they make the film you watch the
film what was like the most fun or like
petrifying part of seeing your real life
like a moment from the film that you saw
I don't think I was ever like really
petrified about people seeing this I was
more petrified that people weren't gonna
like it you know but like the reviews
that I got it's just so incredible it's
better than they ever expected I
expected it to be good because like you
know you have talent like Steven much
and you know being the right and
director for it I mean come on and then
Dwayne is the producer and MGM and
everyone it's just it's incredible but
it just blows me away
it really does so now you start
wrestling I believe like 13 years old
yeah what was it about the sport that
you first fell in love with because it's
so much this performance that right the
salesmanship of it there's a wrestling
aspect your family was involved in all
portions of it right what was it as a
little girl that you said you know what
this is what I love about it well I've
always loved watching WWE like whatever
happens I didn't want to get into the
rest and side of things too much because
it used to scare me I was a young girl
you know I was like oh no I couldn't get
the ring it's too scary my dad was shot
to go one day he's like all right Gideon
and I was like oh good Zak was a pink
Power Ranger and it was the adrenaline
rush that was so addicting like walking
out and just seeing like the five finds
that was in the crowd but they were just
happy to see me you know and I just like
loved that thrill of entertaining people
and and being an exaggerated version of
myself it was just it was a wonderful
feeling right on and now hopefully
you'll become a movie star yeah
hopefully be in there a rock for huge
fans thank you so much what advice would
you give us we want to be the next you
what do you names get mine
what your names are you walk around here
interrupting the rock you like you
haven't seen the Sun in 20 years you
like you just stepped out of Oliver
Twist please sir may I have some more
advice you want some advice here's the
rocks advice shut your mouth thanks
Dwayne yeah so let's talk about this
film you know I feel like some people
would say you're an unconventional
choice to make a movie about wrestling
but I feel like you're a master
storyteller when it comes to telling
stories about unconventional families
from the office through extras is that
what drew you to this one I loved movies
of all kinds I loved superhero movies I
love sci-fi I loved everything out of
action movies but I do for myself as a
person to write direct I always come
back to these if you like slightly
smaller more relatable intimate stories
I think that this one actually has a lot
of scale and scope because she ends up
you know performing in front of
thousands of people but at the core of
it is this family relationship and that
was what I dialed into this this young
woman she's got these dreams of going to
America leaving her tiny town pursuing
it trying to make it in the big time but
these are dreams not just that she's
carrying for herself but also she's
carrying for the family a lot of weight
of expectation from them
she's a woman who's alone she's 4,000
miles from home you know can she make it
it's a real it's rare you find this a
real life rocky style underdog story and
I just thought that was so relatable and
so lovely and the relationship with her
brother was so tender and so strained
and difficult and the family of so
eccentric and colorful it just had all
the things that I I look for in a film
and the fact it happened to be about
wrestling not something that you're
right I was a natural fit for me
it was almost a hearing there there I
kept thinking movies like Billy Elliot I
don't think you need to like ballet now
to love this story of this little boy
who wants to be a ballet dancer so um
yeah I think the rest is almost here
there there talk about this family you
know they are an unconventional family
eccentric family what did you take away
most from them when you know what did
they say to anything look you're telling
us our story you have to do this you
have to get this right what was your
biggest takeaway from meeting them and
telling their story well I felt a
responsibility to get their story right
firstly because you know they are real
people with real lives secondly because
they're wrestlers and they could break
my legs if I get it but um they they're
very honest they're very open and they
talk
what's important to me is these are not
perfect people they are flawed
individuals as are my family as are most
people's families and I didn't want to
paint them like they were Saints you
know Ricky the father will talk openly
about the fact that he had done jail
time at a young age as his wife says
mainly for violence and so there's a lot
of humor there but there's a lot of sort
of darkness and tragedy in the past and
wrestling was something that drew them
out of that that was something that they
talked about it like a religion like it
saved their lives and so that passion
they have for this thing which I didn't
know anything about I really found very
moving and I didn't want to mock them I
didn't want to satirize them or
wrestling I wanted to just celebrate
this warts-and-all family flawed but
loving and and I hope that's what we've
done you know and and they are perfect
characters they're ready-made because
they're larger than life they speak in a
certain way and then having this cast
who could could have then kind of embody
those people was it gotten what mr.
Wayne Johnson how are you proving
cookin yeah and I'm Vin Diesel might I'm
sorry so this film you know in Scott
it's about an unconventional family it's
got the wrestling aspects for you guys
what was the most important thing for
you to really understand most was at the
wrestling part of this film or was it
this family and what they meant to each
other
I died then I think the second thing I
think it's it's the family and the the
specifically uniqueness of this family
yeah but III think it's about a family
unit that is trying to sort of achieve
things individually but also trying to
stay as a family and they ultimately do
that is what seems to be the message of
the film is that they ultimately that
family is more important than a big
contract yeah you know wrestling could
be anything to be connecting ceramic
pottery making you know I mean is it
just it's about family no it's not easy
but you're kind of stuck with them okay
you know they they will never stop
fighting for each other you know you
know in wrestling wrestlers are known
for a move
that didn't known for it kind of defines
them as their character what are you
guys known for if somebody came to you
and said you know Nick's known for this
you know what the movie yeah not the
move necessarily but just in life what
are you known for you the guy that he
always takes a last coffee or always you
know I always leave something on my
plate I always did for him no choice
either and I just a little I just always
have to leave something I don't know why
maybe I'd like to read the guy that
follows Jack and just eats a little bit
he leaves it's thinking of others yeah
how important was it now you guys shot
in the in the town right where where the
family's from and some of it yeah in
Norwich in East Anglian Norfolk how
important was it to the film to be there
and to sort of ending I think the
exteriors it was important obviously but
we shot a lot of it in London but I
think we did some up and passed and all
the scenes in the market are there and
yeah yes we did we covered you guys run
in Norwich is famous covered market
which is a massive landmark and we also
there's a hill outside of prison this is
a lot about a town where the most
everything is a hill outside of prison I
have no idea who wants this to be out
there
you're not just doing this view you're
doing it for the family that you learn
from Paige and did it have to do with
her family or was it about wrestling um
that I learned from her I don't think it
was about family or wrestling I think
family was something that was given is
something that is with her and supports
her throughout the whole thing and
that's so wonderful to watch wrestling
that's something that she can do and
she's brilliant at that the thing that I
completely fell in love with and I loved
learning from her was sake being your
own voice and being so proud of the fact
that you are utterly different and you
are a little bit wonky and there is
nothing wrong with that and and really
owning it and I think that's what
wrestling fans and and that's hopefully
what I think well wrestling comes before
the film came out will come out and and
and our fans are now coming from the
film I hope I hope that's something that
they're attracted to and front with the
real page as well you know what was
something that you learned from maybe
from this family's unconventional family
that you're applying to your own life
was there anything you took away I don't
think I took anything away cuz I've got
my own family unit and I think we're
pretty we in our groove and you won't
happen making it happen but I just I
love the nights I think they're
extraordinary and what I what I love and
admire about them is they're totally
honest like there's no whispering behind
doors there's no kind of man-eating
anything it's all dirty pretty shitty
brilliant it's all out there for them
all to kind of jump in and discuss and I
think that's why they work and why we
love them why we love them in this film
you know Russell's are known for having
like a finishing move that's kind of
what they're known for defined by if we
asked your friends and family what
you're known for oh you know whether or
not you you like too much coffee whether
or not you're a big fan girl of Game of
Thrones what would you what would they
say about you known for
I mean I'm known for having a really
weird
laughs how do we even say no okay really
with noise I make a very funny noise
with my throat
so I wonder if actually that maybe
that's what my maybe I do that sound
when I'm wrestling co-signature yeah
yeah what are you gonna be known for
juju us we're wrestling move yeah and
it's not real I don't really do that on
you